this is tim hussein reading for reviewer
richard wakeling the one thing that
immediately stands out about trek to
yomi is its striking visual style set
during japan's edo period trektoyomi
captures feudal japan with a grainy
black and white fill a reminiscent of
classic samurai cinema particularly the
movies of legendary filmmaker akira
kurosawa almost every single frame in
trektiomi could be a painting such is
the beauty of its immaculate composition
for all its gravitas however the
side-scrolling action game underneath it
all continually underwhelms when two
heavy steel katanas clash against each
other with a subdued and weightless
whimper it becomes clear that tractor
yomi lacks the substance to match his
fantastic style
[Music]
most of your time in tractor yom is
spent cutting down enemies with
protagonist hiroki's deadly katana
combat adopts a familiar structure as
you utilize light and heavy attacks
parries dodge rolls and ammo limited
range weapons like a bow and shurikens
to carve through enemy encounters
stamina governs how often you can block
and attack before becoming winded and
leaving yourself open to attack but both
health and stamina can be upgraded by
exploring and finding pickups off the
beaten path you'll also unlock new
combos as you progress including one
that lets you swing backwards
useful for dealing with enemies who
emerge from behind and another that
leads with a heavy attack before
transitioning into a combination of
lightning fast strikes you'll feel
appropriately deadly able to cut down
most enemies with a couple of sword
swings but this does mean combat is a
cakewalk for the most part armored
enemies aren't quite as easy to kill
since they're able to sustain more
damage and generally have more elaborate
combos and enemy types like those
wielding spears force you to close the
distance before you can strike a killing
blow the problem with trek to yomi's
combat is that dispatching these foes
rarely ever feels satisfying there's a
lack of fluidity when transitioning
between different actions and the
animations are stuttery and stilted
lending everything a sense of
weightlessness that's at odds with the
game's cinematography
[Music]
parries are decidedly underwhelming too
and enemies tend to attack one at a time
even when they have you surrounded
eliminating much need in even using the
mechanic it all results in combat taking
on a formulaic rhythm as you simply
parry attack and then repeat regardless
of which enemy type you're confronted
with
there's little of substance outside of
combat as well seeking alternate paths
can lead to the discovery of fun
environmental hazards that let you
bypass entire combat sequences
altogether cutting a rope to send logs
tumbling onto some hapless bandits
sitting around a campfire for instance
or opening up a dam to wipe out a group
with the rushing water
there's also a single rudimentary puzzle
where you have to look at three kanji
characters in the environment and then
line them up correctly that's reused
multiple times there's a degree of
challenge in having to differentiate
between various symbols but this creates
a dissonance in your role as hiroki
considering as someone who's japanese he
would presumably read kanji and not be
confused by these puzzles ultimately the
visuals do a lot of the heavy lifting
track to yomi's cinematic presentation
is eye-catching right from the very
beginning the game opens with haroki a
young samurai in training practicing
with his sword alongside his master this
sequence serves as a combat tutorial
that blends in nicely with hiroki's
origin and seamlessly shifts into the
motivating force of the story
things suddenly go awry when your master
is summoned to protect the village from
an invading force of bandits so he
charges off spear in hand and tells you
to stay put that obviously doesn't
happen as hiroki quickly leaves a dojo
in search of his master and it's here
that trektoyami's arresting visual style
reveals itself in both subtle and
spectacular ways after descending the
steps leading into town the camera
positions itself behind shopkeepers and
busy market stores as you weave between
silhouettes you're given full range of
3d motion when exploring the environment
but the camera is fixed in order to
frame each scene as though it were a
movie
the lens sits in tight as you move
through the village and pass its many
denizens before panning out once hiraki
emerges through the main gate letting
you soak in the vast rice fields and
mountains rising in the distance fluidly
transitioning from the intimacy of the
village to the grand scale of the
outside world as you confront the
violent bandits bearing down on your
home trektoyomi moves to a 2d plane to
present its side-scrolling combat
it's an effective perspective switch
that results in numerous instances where
you face off with lone warriors against
scenic backdrops further latching on to
that cinematic feeling kurosawa's
inspiration isn't just confined to a
shallow black and white filter either
there might not be anything here that
can truly match the japanese director's
brilliance but that doesn't prevent trek
to yomi from being an excellent homage
its use of natural phenomena like wind
rain fire and mist creates movement that
breathes life into each frame in a very
kurosawa-esque fashion
occasionally the camera will even move
through a scene as though the director
himself was behind the lens effortlessly
flowing from a wide angle shot to a
close-up and then back again in one
fluid motion
because it was built from the ground up
as a black and white game track to
yomi's image really pops well there's a
clear understanding of contrast shadows
and the clash between light and dark
tones that prevent each frame from
looking as flat as they would if a basic
filter was simply applied while
kurosawa's films are often slow paced
and methodical trektiomi is anything but
which is one of the many areas in which
its story and characters veer away from
the stylings of the influential
filmmaker hiroki's master is eventually
slain by the roving bandits attacking
his village so the young samurai makes a
vow to protect his home and those he
loves against any future threats later
on once hiroki has grown into a hardened
samurai the village once again erupts in
violence sending hiroki on a tale of
revenge as he confronts his own guilt at
failing to uphold the vow he made to his
dying master
it's a simple story that moves along at
a fairly brisk pace often squeezing in
less than a minute of dialogue before
you're on to the next fight the
emotional beats don't quite pay off
since you don't spend enough time with
any of the characters become invested
but it never tries to stretch itself too
thin
this is a refined tale that complements
the action without ever truly being
compelling at times it's disappointing
that it doesn't do more only briefly
touching on shinto mythology for example
but it serves its purpose generating
momentum with its revenge fueled romp
[Music]
the faults of its gameplay are
especially disappointing given that
track to yomi is such a gorgeous and
spellbinding game to look at its visuals
are evocative of classic samurai cinema
in a way that few other games have
managed successfully it captures the
look and feel of kurosawa's masterpieces
with aplomb it's easy to recommend if
you have an xbox game pass subscription
if only to marvel at each meticulously
crafted frame if only the game beneath
it all wasn't such an unfortunate
letdown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]